we have a voicemail number that number
is 219 to David P
I'm gonna play a voicemail for you from
a caller who is very agitated but this
doesn't seem to be a right winger
attacking me although they are attacking
me but not from a right-wing perspective
this is someone who apparently expects a
trump dictatorship
and is worried that I'm going to press
the fu button on them which I don't know
what that is maybe it means that we have
to bleep voicemails I'm not sure so dude
I really you push the fu button on me
because I was on a rant no you're making
money on this too you love talking about
this this is uh this is disgusting
what's going on you realize nothing's
gonna happen to this guy so hit the fu
button yeah I can't do it who now can
look what's our current we're going to
be under dictatorship by Donald Trump
and his disgusting skank hold daughter
in this song oof who watch and see what
happens goodbye before you hit the fu
button well if there's no f-bombs
there's no reason to hit the fu button
which I don't have the fu button is like
Pat bleeping stuff so listen this guy's
pessimistic I get it I get I say I I
don't you know the the whole skank hole
thing as a way to reference to Ivanka
I'm not big on that but I sympathize
with the um sentiment that nothing's
going to happen and you know supposedly
Trump's arrest was today and I kept
saying this is what Trump claims we
don't know that that's the case it
doesn't seem as though that's happening
although maybe by the time we publish
this episode Trump will have been cuffed
and booked but I I doubt it
um I sympathize with this feeling that
nothing is going to be done
Trump won't be held accountable and he
will end up back in power with his
authoritarian delusions and dreams I
hope that that isn't the case but I
sympathize with the frustration on
today's bonus show we will talk about
President Joe Biden issuing his first
veto what was the veto over and what are
the implications we will discuss it
secondly Paris is increasingly under the
weight of stinky trash uncollected trash
has mounted to ten thousand tons because
of strikes that are going on and as a
result I am canceling my trip to Paris
scheduled for two weeks from now no I I
had a tentative visit to Paris when I'm
going to be in in Europe in a few weeks
but for other reasons it's not happening
it has nothing to do with the trash and
thirdly North Carolina
is urging the Supreme Court to throw out
a major elections case this is a case
we've talked about before this is a case
our bonus show audience will be familiar
with and it is a very consequential case
we will talk about why North Carolina is
saying to the Supreme Court throw it in
the trash flush it down the toilet 10 to
15 times all of those stories and more
will be discussed today
when producer Pat joins me on the bonus
show we do a bonus show every single day
every weekday every day that there's a
show if you want access to the bonus
show simply sign up at joinpakman.com
and if you would like access but
the financial commitment is too much for
you at this time you can request a free
membership at the following URL
David packman
.com
slash free membership don't email me
about it okay sign up to get a free
membership at davidpackman.com
membership I'll see you on the bonus
show otherwise we'll be back here
tomorrow